hey what's up guys my name is luciano
welcome to
another hazel dev vlog it feels like
it's been so long since the last one and
to be honest it has
because i don't think i've done that
much lately that's okay because these
development logs as always are about
recapping what it is that i have done as
well as thoughts for the future and also
just my thoughts about the whole process
of developing a game engine
in general now today i want to talk
about getting things done to a certain
level of
doneness or perfection so in other words
should you leave a feature let's just
say
medium rare or should you get it all the
way to well done as you can see i'm
sitting in the kitchen so that's
probably why these analogies are
slightly inspired by food
now i recently put up a video called
just do it i'll have it linked up there
where i mentioned that done is better
than
perfect which is kind of a common term
thrown around the industry
any creative industry what it means is
that it's better to get something done
and release it and move on to something
else rather than just iterating on
the same thing over and over again until
you get it to the point that it's
perfect because
well for one that might never happen but
also it's important to recognize that
striving for perfection is not
always the right move and today i'm
going to throw a real curveball into
this
and talk about the opposite of that
which is more along the lines of
spending more time on the same feature
to get it down to a higher standard
rather than leaving it where it is and
moving on to something new
how do you decide whether or not you're
going to spend more time perfecting a
feature rather than moving on and doing
something new
when that feature is more or less there
and i mean that
really is a question how do you decide
i think this problem really presents
itself a lot more strongly when you're
working on
a large project so if you're working on
a game engine
there is just so much going on that
you're never really going to have
everything done to perfection it's just
not gonna happen
i mean look at the other game engines
they're worked on by hundreds of
engineers
for decades and they're not done and so
if you're a single
person working on a large project such
as a game engine
knowing when to stop and knowing when
something is good enough before you move
on
i think is a really difficult skill to
learn and it's something that you will
probably likely
screw up with and then come back to and
then keep on improving certain features
because you're like okay
there's i just can't live with this
feature being
at this level and it sucks because i've
worked on larger projects i've seen what
large
teams are capable of achieving and it's
really cool
it really is amazing when i was a lot
less experienced let's just say eight
years ago
i really had no idea of the scope of
something like
a game engine so when i got something
done to a certain standard or to a
certain level of complexity
or feature completeness or whatever you
want to call it i was happy with it
but now now that i've gotten more
experience and i know how larger
projects are put together
there's always this feeling at the back
of my mind that's like well i know that
this
isn't up to the professional standard
that i might be used to
i know that this feature is not very
good but i have to leave it
there and i have to move on to something
else otherwise i'm going to be stuck
writing this feature for the rest of my
life
potentially i mean to give you a really
good example let's talk a little bit
about rendering
rendering and graphics is my favorite
area of programming or i should say
probably game engine
development the reason i started
programming in the first place was
because i was really into
3d art and i wanted to write my own
renderer and so if we look at hazel and
we look at the state of the renderer in
hazel
i mean i've been looking at it over the
past week and i hate it
i don't hate it because i've written it
i think that for what it is it's
probably
not the worst piece of code i've ever
written however
there's it's just capable of so much
more there's so much more in me
that i want to pour into that renderer
because it's just it doesn't even it's
it's to me it's total
junk but if i just decided that i was
going to focus on
hazel's renderer until it was like more
or less let's just say
nearing unreal engines level or i
shouldn't say that because that's
probably impossible but
nearing a more professional level then
that would take me years
and so after three years pass i might
have a brilliant renderer that's capable
of rendering really nice graphics and
it's written really cleanly
and the code is organized great and it's
extensible and supports all the latest
features and it supports ray tracing and
it's amazing
but then it wouldn't i wouldn't have
written a game engine i would just have
a renderer and that's it
but what about you know like the energy
component system what about the whole
game runtime system what about c-sharp
scripting and interacting with things
what about a level editor so that you
can actually place like
entities into the world and do stuff
with them none of that would exist not
to mention probably only support one
rendering api
one platform and that's it there's just
so much to think about
and there's so much to do that i find
that obviously i have to just cut
features
short and i have to really really focus
on smaller chunks
to get anything done and i have to make
sure that i'm basically
instead of doing like a depth first
search this isn't one of those
great programming analogies again that i
just came up with on spotlight i always
do but instead of like a depth first
search where we basically drill down on
a feature and we go all the way to the
end
we have to do more of a breadth first
approach which is like okay let's
get like a triangle rendering and then
let's move on to like maybe creating an
empty system or
some of the ui for the editor or
something like that
we have to approach this whole thing as
a whole rather than drilling down on one
specific feature
now i'm saying we have to we have to
this is just my approach and this is
what's going through my head this isn't
necessarily
the way to write a game engine but if
you are doing something like that by
yourself you have to realize
how many sacrifices you really do have
to make in order to get
a game engine more or less feature
complete even if it is kind of at that
mvp minimum viable product
feature level and to be honest that's
what i've been thinking about
these past few weeks and in a sense it's
absolutely heartbreaking
apart from the fact that that itself is
kind of demotivating there's also the
whole
situation going on with where i live i
live in melbourne australia and for
those of you who
live here or know about what's going on
here at the moment we are in a pretty
serious
lockdown we've got a curfew where we're
not allowed to leave the house after 8
pm and before 5am and we're only allowed
to travel in a five kilometer radius
from
where we live i mean i can't even see my
parents so because of that i've really
been re-evaluating what i've been doing
i think i've been looking at games such
as ghost of sushima and just spending a
little bit more time doing more
entertaining things to me i've been
playing a lot of age of empires 2 with
my friends
that's been a really good way to spend
some time socializing with people
other than my wife who lives with me
which is really i'm really grateful for
that
and i've also really enjoyed streaming
on twitch i mean being able to share the
work that i'm doing with hundreds of
people watching the stream and
interacting with me it's
it's amazing and to be honest it's the
closest thing that i've experienced
since i left ea and a real kind of team
and i'm honestly super grateful for all
of you i think streaming is something
that i'm definitely gonna do a lot more
of
in the future so throughout these past
few weeks and
all of this thinking about what's going
on and
the done is better than perfect but on
the other hand getting stuff
done to a higher degree and to a higher
level of satisfaction really is also
something that i think is important what
i've decided to do
is to take a little bit of a step back
from hazel and
instead of trying to get all of the
features in at once which is something
that i tend to do and then later i just
get overwhelmed
i'm going to take a look at what we
already have because i think that hazel
dev
is at a really good place right now i
mean you could basically make a game
with it it's got c-sharp scripting
it's got 3d rendering it's got 2d
physics you can kind of put something
together with it and in fact that's
something that i am going to do soon on
my stream i want to start building games
building little games
using hazel using the actual editor
using actual c-sharp scripting
without actually going in and
programming any c plus plus code that's
something that i'm really excited
to do in the future and obviously i'll
have to add features to the c
plus plus side of things to facilitate a
lot of the
functionality that's probably missing
and that i would like to add along the
way
but that's also part of the fun and
that's how we get to a point where hazel
ends up being more feature complete
so taking a look at what hazel dev
already has
and then just refining that that's
something that i'm going to spend
the next month or two going over i am
going to go over the renderer and refine
it
i'm going to be integrating things like
spur v which is a shader compiler which
we can also use to compile into various
other shading languages as well as
reflective on the shaders to get
information about things like uniform
buffers and
vertex attribute layouts because the way
that we're currently doing that is just
by using a simple glsl parser that i
wrote that's also going to set us
up for multiple rendering apis and for
multiple platforms which is also
something that i'm going to be taking a
look at
in the next month or two i'm going to be
taking a look seriously into mac os and
linux support
and everything that we need to do to
make that happen i'm going to spend a
lot of time polishing what hazel
actually has and lifting that up to a
higher degree of quality just to a
higher standard
instead of trying to jam in a whole
bunch of new features and to be honest
i'm really excited to do that because in
a sense that's a lot easier
than trying to learn all these new
things and deal with problems you've
never dealt with before
it's time to just get back to this and
just improve the overall
quality of it and i honestly can't wait
to do that now apart from the fact that
i will be keeping you guys up to date in
these hateful devlogs and hopefully next
time i'll try some code and
all the the actual ways that i've
improved the code i guess
apart from that i am also going to be
streaming myself doing a lot of this
work now
in the past i used to stream myself
working on hazel dev only for patreons
but
i'm not going to be doing that anymore
i'm going to be streaming for everyone
on twitch over the past week of
streaming on tuition general i found
that apart from the fact that it's super
cool
to have an audience watch you and
comment on what you're doing and it just
it just
motivates me to keep going more because
i know there's people watching me
apart from all of that a lot of you guys
are excellent at spotting mistakes or
just
bouncing ideas off of sometimes i'll not
know how to do something or i'll
consider doing it a certain way and i'll
be thinking out loud and just talking to
you and
and someone will suggest that i take a
different approach this happened just
last night for example but anyway
hopefully that makes sense to you guys
the kind of new direction i guess of
hazel dev and
look i mean there's no doubt in my mind
that maybe i'll polish up some things
and then i'll just want to integrate
this new feature and i'll probably will
do that
but i guess for me it's more about
realizing that
this game engine is is it's a huge piece
of technology something that i'm really
passionate about and that i really want
to do well and properly
and so sometimes you just need to go
back and do the same thing
again and make it better instead of just
trying to constantly
move forward because as you do that that
tech debt just
keeps building up and eventually it's
going to be completely unmanageable
and you're probably going to crash and
burn and burn out and that's not
something i want to do
because of course i'm here for the long
haul
anyway i want to thank all of you guys
for helping to support me
this community means a lot to me and i
definitely wouldn't be sitting here
making a game engine
if it wasn't for you so i really am
grateful to all of you guys thank you so
much i want to also mention that i
finally
have merch check this out to those of
you who remember my
original streams and how i used to
always have a turkey
either on the oven or on the stove i
finally
finally have some turkey merchandise
this design was actually
made by my wife i think she did an
amazing job i'll have a link in the
description below if you guys want to
check this merch out i'm still kind of
refining a few things with it
so things might change there might be
more types of clothing available we
might tweak the design or just resize it
in the future but to those of you who do
want to show your support
and get this amazing sweatshirt in this
case but i've also got like t-shirts and
hoodies and other stuff
thank you so much and i hope you enjoy
it it really did come out
amazing as always if you're more
interested in the code than the
clothes then check out patreon.com the
channel
where you can actually get access to
hazel hazeldev's source code and there's
actually an amazing team an amazing
small team that's part of the community
that i've built up that are helping me
make decisions
as well as actually contribute to that
code which i think
is pretty cool but anyway i hope you
guys enjoyed this video thank you all
for watching
have an amazing day and i will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you